foreign
[Music]
this is Star Talk Cosmic queries Edition
and this one is grab bag Chuck I think
that's your favorite one grab bag is
that right yeah I kind of did the grab
bag you know just because you reach in
and whatever comes out potluck
potluck is never a bad thing right it's
just a different thing yeah exactly
potluck is great because you don't know
what you're getting you get there and
there's a bunch of good stuff normally
and usually it's people's best stuff
right they don't bring more stuff so
exactly nobody brings their you know
crap dish their b list dish right right
if you say like what do you bringing to
the potluck and they're like my string
bean casserole is like no you got to go
I like string beans I like string beans
too but you can't be bringing the recipe
off the Campbell's Soup to the pot
I mean you got it you know now if you if
you have an original recipe for a string
being casserole that's the difference
because that one was from the mushroom
uh cream of mushroom soup the cream of
mushroom soup you dumped that in that
made everything yeah exactly right you
could make anything with cream of
mushroom soup Campbell's it had enough
salt to serve an army yeah but anyhow
wait so you got a whole set of questions
I haven't seen them or heard them so
let's bring them on all right well we
can jump right into this I love this
first question this is from Amanda and
Amanda uh clearly uh believes that
everybody knows who she is because that
is all there is it's just Amanda it just
says Amanda okay if you don't know then
you blew it bro if you don't know you
blew it bro everybody everybody who
needs to know knows a man knows Amanda
so
um
Amanda says you get a lot of questions
about a lot of things
what is the question you wish people
would ask you but they normally do not
oh wow yeah let's see I don't I don't
wish people to ask questions that's not
how I think about life I see myself as a
servant of people's curiosity that
gurgles up natively within them not as
people who will serve my needs or my
wants by asking me questions that I wish
they would however what she's saying
though is what is the question
that would
excite you that people may not know to
ask you helping out so they're curious
helping her out in that question I am
helping her out because you know I I get
exactly what you're saying and so I'm
just reframing Amanda's question and
yeah here's one here's one that no one
has asked and I don't know why okay I
spent a whole chapter on it in my book
astrophysics for people in a hurry
uh-huh the title the chapter is on Earth
as it is in heaven
and the question is how do we know that
the laws of physics we discover here on
Earth
apply elsewhere in the universe is that
an assumption is it a article of faith
is it and if we if they apply Across the
Universe how do we know they also apply
throughout time
because as we look out in the universe
we're looking back in time
and so no one asked that and so I get I
guess I get to put that one in and
that's that's awesome and if you want to
know the answer to that people all you
got to do is go buy meals
that's all you guys do
you get the answer
next question next question no so by the
way these are all asked by patreon
members correct I think and you you have
access to this currently with our new
tier system at the entry level patreon
yes you get it's five dollars a month I
think
um anybody who joins patreon if you join
patreon and support StarTalk radio at
patreon.com Star Talk radio then you
automatically get to ask us questions
and last I checked isn't like an
entry-level cup of coffee at Starbucks
five dollars that's it that's actually
cheap that's just a regular cup of
coffee yeah you know I mean once you add
the plutonium to it it costs a lot more
you know
that's that's what they're doing there's
so many I I only get coffee yeah other
stuff is just too deep for me at
Starbucks and it's all sugar
no I mean don't you say no sugar or you
say you know no I'm saying though it's
like a caramel macchiato half calf you
know whatever
I can't like it's all like it it's a
dessert didn't they they like deliver a
dessert yeah yeah half of them are the
Frappuccino yes right right right right
okay right yeah I can't do it I can't
you know I mean all right well if you
get one of those every day you can
surely become a member by paying that
once a month per month right right
that's only one day skip
skip the banana frap for one day
no I mean skip the banana frap with
double the whipped cream for one day and
you support us for the entire month
there you go all right so my answer for
Amanda is very simple actually
um we initially we didn't know and
here's an interesting little historical
note Isaac Newton comes up with his laws
of gravity and and he's rocking the
house with these he can explain Earth's
uh the moon's orbit around the Earth
Earth motion around the Moon he explains
Jupiter's satellites in orbit around
Jupiter right which was the first time
we calculated something orbiting
something else other than either
ourselves or the Sun so it's like oh my
gosh this is badass Universe universal
law of gravitation and then
uh Herschel William Herschel discovers
planet Uranus
with this telescope this is a planet
orbiting just beyond Saturn
okay so it's a modern planet was not
known to the Ancients even though it's
named with a with a Roman god and so
you're an Arnold's right was Greek and
then there was very close to that in
Roman any in in Latin anyhow
that planet it has it's orbiting the Sun
but they kept tracking it and it was not
matching Newton's Laws it was deviating
and people said okay we found the limit
to Newton's Laws it only goes out to
Saturn
Beyond Saturn we got to make other laws
to apply to the rest of the universe and
somebody else said nah Newton was too
badass for that let's let's assume his
laws are correct
and then wonder what could be perturbing
Uranus's orbit hmm
in the way that we see and so some
brilliant mathematicians got together a
French mathematician primarily Le verier
and he calculated with Newton's laws and
you have to invert the equation
mathematically which is not easy to do
instead of having an equation saying
here's an object what's the field of
gravity at this distance
you have to ask a different question
where would an object have to be and at
what distance to influence this object
in this way
that's a whole other way to use that law
of physics and the arithmetic and and
the calculus so he does that predicts
that if Newton's laws are accurate and
we didn't come to the end of Newton's
Laws if it they're accurate there should
be a planet right over here take a look
take a look and sure enough that night
that night
uh there's a telescope in Germany I
forgot the guy's name who was tasked who
tasked himself to this fill him for that
Wilhelm Ludwig right
we'll just call him
that's it Chuck that's racist I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure it is too but let
me tell you something if there's one
people that cannot complain about racism
it is the Germans okay
if Claire Chuck is still in his race
therapy classes exactly all right let's
all right so that night he said I'll
look here in this little box that
leveria is telling me to look and sure
enough
planet Neptune is discovered look at
that where it should have been and at
the distance it needed to be to perturb
the orbit of Uranus and so Newton's Laws
correct then sometime later we found
binary Stars orbiting each other far
outside of the solar system
they're following Newton's laws of
gravity
then we find galaxies in orbit we find
uh and we take this out to the edge of
the universe wow okay now it turns out
there's a limit to Newton's law as we
find out they do fail in the regime of
extremely high gravity
and so you need Einstein's laws to
describe where Newton's Laws fail so
it's not a matter of place and time it's
a matter of severity
of how much mass and energy have you
compacted into a small volume so you
can't use Newton's laws to describe
black holes for example right but you
can does it describe practically
everything else in the universe so
they're highly useful we got to the moon
on Newton's laws in 1968 and 69. so so
and and
we can look at Spectra you can take
carbon or nitrogen or oxygen and and
um and you burn it and it can send off
features in a spectrum okay which is the
fingerprint of each element and each
element has a unique fingerprint on the
periodic table some are complex some are
simple some are fascinatingly ordered
but each element is unique now we look
out in the universe oh my gosh halfway
across the universe carbon showing up
exactly as it would have on earth oh but
wait a minute the universe is expanding
so there's a shift in the wavelength of
light oh by how much well by this much
so let's shift in the Spectrum here on
Earth there's the carbon fingerprint and
that oh wow look at that right in
exactly the configuration it needs to be
but the whole pattern which shifted
according to how fast the thing is
expanding away from us and we could take
that to the edge of the freaking
Universe which takes us not only across
space but through the depths of time
itself and the spacing of those features
is very sensitive to quantum physics and
the speed of light and so that also
tells us that the law not only do the
basic laws that we know of apply but
also other things like the speed of
light uh the quantum other things that
that are tied up with other measurements
that enable those measurements to even
exist at all those work out too hence
they called the universal laws of
physics look at that and that's what
gives you that obnoxious thing which is
kind of true there's the laws of physics
and everything after that is opinion wow
wow look at that that's completely
obnoxious but it's kind of I don't I
don't think it's obnoxious when it works
but it's kind of mostly true yeah it's
yeah yeah you're not obnoxious but it's
it's it's a little jordanesque yeah yeah
you know like Michael Jordan was like
you know you ask him who's the greatest
player of all time and he'll just be
like man we don't need to have that
conversation Ah that's how you answer
that yes you know but you know what he
means when he says that you know exactly
what he's saying what he's saying is I
am the greatest player of all time but
he's like man
because he's not going to say it himself
right so right there you go right okay
so so I'm just remembering now uh with
the help of our producers uh Johann
Gottfried guile
g-a-l-l-e in German I'm not sure how you
would pronounce that but he he's the guy
who went to the telescope and found
Neptune at the commands of the mass of
the French mathematician
so yeah there it is
laws of physics that's why it's you know
physicists I think have good right good
good justification to have a certain uh
cocky confidence when we invoke our laws
of physics that we know apply throughout
the Universe and all of time because
listen that when this stuff works
halfway across the damn Galaxy and then
it works when other galaxies they're
doing the same thing that's right it's
like it's hard not to feel you know just
a bit confident right it doesn't mean
it's not justification to be an a-hole
in your character and personality just
when you're declaring your confidence in
a discovery or a mistake you know it's
okay right yeah no that's pretty cool
man better and listen Amanda what a what
a great way to get us rocking on the
show okay took down the whole damn
segment there who cares drop another one
let's see what we can fit in here okay
let's go to Brittany manicotti men
mankati not Mena mencotti Britney yeah
manicotti is like one of my favorite
pasta dishes there you go so she says hi
Neil hey Chuck I'm an aspiring Chef in
Louisville Kentucky I was wondering what
the future of the culinary arts may look
like with if and when we colonize
elsewhere in our solar system or even
further oh oh okay I'm gonna answer that
real quick and then we go to a break so
you'd have to make adjustments for
different atmospheric pressures right
and if we're let's assume we could
recreate the air mixture of nitrogen
oxygen the different atmospheric
pressure will affect it and if it's not
the exactly the same amount of oxygen
then things will burn at different rates
if you have a coal oven or even your
your your gas burning because more
oxygen it'll burn more more violently
because oxygen promotes combustion all
of that you'll have there'll be a diff
you'll meet you'll have the moon
cookbook and the Mars cookbook wow and
something else we discovered and we're
not quite sure what causes this in orbit
people's taste buds wane
so the foods that they tends to people
who never had it before they add hot
sauce to their Foods just to sort of
punch it up punch it up punch it up a
notch we don't know if it's because
you're weightless or because the
pressure is a little different in the
air it's like being on a mountain top
you don't you don't put spacecraft at
the same pressure as atmospheric
pressure it's just not necessary because
you're not you know running marathons
right you can breathe a thinner air like
on a Mountaintop you can breathe a
thinner air and you'll be fine but all
the forces that operate on your
olfactory senses you might need a
special version of your recipe for it to
work on the moon but here's something
before we take it out to the break that
um you have to watch out because even if
you have a delicious meal on the moon if
you open a restaurant
it's not going to have any atmosphere
I got it you got you I see what you did
there that's a dad joke but I'm allowed
because I am a dad all right let's say
we're going to take a quick break and
say I'm gonna say that's your cratered
oh
oh oh
good one Chuck
good one get to get out joked that's
good I like that let's take our first
break and we'll come right back to start
talk Cosmic queries grab bag Edition
with my co-host Chuck Nice
we're back segment two Cosmic queries
grab bag Edition Chuck you just pulling
them out random out of there yeah so
what else you have here we go let's go
to Kayla nickel
from Boise Idaho
it's Boise
oh Boise Boise Idaho and what's the
person's name again so this is Kayla
Nichol from Boise hey Kayla hey Dr Tyson
Lord nice do you think warp drive for
Interstellar Chapel is possible uh we
know how to do it on paper so the
question is not is do laws of physics
prevent it the question is do
engineering
uh abilities or knowledge or material
substances enable it that's really what
that comes down to so is it possible in
principle and so in principle it's
possible so the math Works math Works
takes space in front of you and create a
density field and collapse it and
correct move through it and then you're
moving faster than the speed of light
but you're not moving
but you're not moving faster than the
speed of light oh Chuck says that
perfectly oh check nice shucky baby so
so there are two ways you can think of
this one of them is you Bunch up waves
of space-time in front of you okay and
then you sort of surf them oh uh on the
crest of those waves and then you
stretch the waves out behind you and in
that way you go faster than light but
it may be that wormholes get invented
before that
because a wormhole is a tear through
your location in space and time it
crosses through a higher Dimension and
re-enters
you're another location in another
location wow and that reminds me of my
fast story I've said it a couple of
times but now is a good time to say it I
was at Charlotte Airport had to go from
a big plane to a little plane and my
luggage didn't have wheels it was like a
garment bag and and my backpack and I
said I would regret this I felt like I
walked three miles but it was probably
only a mile but it felt like three miles
I got to my little plane gate and I
thought I'd be clever geeky and I
tweeted this back when tweeting was a a
fun thing to do rather than dipping your
toe into the cesspool
of human hatred right okay all right
back when you just tweet thoughts right
fun thoughts so I tweeted and I said
can't wait till the day we have
wormholes
because then all Gates will be adjacent
to one another right I thought that's it
you know I'm card carrying geek that's a
good tweet and then
however geeky you are
there's always someone who's geekier
than you because that Spectrum goes to
Infinity right so someone thinking you
only get to be king geek for a day it's
not even a full day not even the full
day somebody's there to unseat you the
work is out it's like a little geekier
new geek in town
so the person said uh Dr Tyson the day
we have wormholes you won't need
airports there you go it was like
whoa whoa how deep in real time guys so
so wormles might just make all that
obsolete is my point but no we're not
anywhere close and and just to be clear
when people said oh we'll never have
heavier than air flight you know people
like to cite that as well that
scientists were wrong when they said
that scientists never said that you know
okay idiot engineers said that right
here's here's how you know there is of
course the owner of dirigible companies
they said that too the graph Zeppelin
family said that exactly right
so so the reason why you know that is
because birds are heavier than air right
and they can fly there you go this one
was not a hard thing so what you should
have said is we don't know how to
imitate a bird yet one day we might
rather than say we never will
then came will never travel faster than
the sound barrier the word barrier
started you getting used for it like oh
my gosh you can't cross it well why did
you use the word barrier in the first
place all right why don't you just say
the sound speed of sound right it's just
a sound threshold threshold thank you
thank you does it sound barrier and then
you had people who will never cross the
sound barrier meanwhile rifle bullets at
that time routinely travel faster than
sound uh so does the crack of a whip at
the very tip of the wick whip that
little crack is like a mini Sonic Boom
as it goes faster than sound we had
things travel faster than sound plus
everybody knew Mothra travels faster
than sound I mean come on now if that
wasn't evidence enough that's true no
remember was it Mothra or was it
um no it wasn't Mothra Rodan Rodan oh
Rodan yes well Martha was the moth right
Martha is the big yeah furry one yeah
Rodan is like the pterodactyl who yes
the pterodactyl okay and so uh but but
my point is we had things in nature that
could do it and so to say we will never
be able to do it is very little
confidence in our own Ingenuity because
all we had to do was mimic nature on
that level so right now we don't know
anything that's making wormholes and
things so but with the math works so
maybe one day but not any time that I
can foresee
nice well that was fun thanks all right
Kayla thank you Kayla from Boise hey
from Boise Boise all right yeah boys see
um this is of course the Violetta
Violetta yeah buy a letter is she
married with children by now how old is
this guy
no she's like the oldest questioner yeah
no she's just 14 and uh okay no I knew
that I knew that you know why I knew
that well I know I knew that because her
mother brought her to New York City
oh my gosh nice and I said well we you
got to come visit so they visited my
office and and but the child still kept
asking questions
is she ever gonna shut up
so it's it's a it's a level of curiosity
that people often lose right around her
age right now age 13 14 and so if she
maintained that I said I asked the
stupid grown-up question what do you
want to be when you grow up I felt
stupid asking it and she said yeah I'll
be a scientist and she's on the right
path so well listen when we started she
was like Violetta the nine-year-old I
think she was
Violet of the 14 year old plus she's
into sports and things so good she'll
have a whole full complete life there
you go coming down the pipe okay so what
do you got Violet uh Violetta says this
I was wondering
we have various measurements for
traveling at x velocity through space
which is distance uh divided by time
like meters per second but what would or
see right there she's showing off she's
showing off a little bit throwing some
algebraic I'm a letter Flex though
you know what I mean I'm like go ahead
girl go ahead all right you go girl you
go girl you think do you think
um she says but what would or do we call
the measurement for traveling through
time and what would it or does that look
like oh oh traveling through I've never
thought of that because when you're
traveling over distance the the thing of
the metric there that we all care about
is your speed that's right your distance
divided by time now if time is what
you're traveling through
do we are we thinking about the speed
with which you travel through time
that's a different one no I never
thought of that but here's the other
thing
does speed make any real difference when
you are when time is the medium through
which you're traveling oh because
usually when you talk about speed you
say do I really have an hour to kill to
do this exactly whereas in time you just
wipe out the hour because you're
traveling through time because your trap
time is the medium okay
interesting right time is yeah
yeah like if you have access to a time
machine these these words will never
come out of here now your mouth we don't
have time to finish the report right
look said no one ever who had access to
a time machine right right so let me
think how about this you will need a
device
that when you travel through time
keeps track of
how far you have traveled in distance
right not how long it took you not how
long right the time doesn't matter just
how far the distance because as I've
said before on this program if I have a
time machine right here and I go back
one day
okay if that's all I do is go back one
day
I will reappear in the vacuum of space
because Earth is not in this position
one day ago
okay in fact I'll be in the way and
Earth will slam into me
so because things are moving you can't
just go through time
and land in a place you expect to land
unless you also plot a trajectory
through space
so if you want to be where that time
machine is in that room a day later six
months later whatever you got to move
with to Earth's plot if it's six months
you're on the other side of the sun
thank you it's two seasons later thank
you all right you gotta track all of
this
so I bet it's not a speed calculation
it's a distance calculation that we're
going to have to carry in our Hip Pocket
right unless we all die suffocating in
the vacuum of space yeah and let me tell
you something Violetta if you were 14
years old asking these type of questions
uh
don't ever smoke weed what that's what
she eats
just leave it alone you don't you don't
you don't need it yeah other people need
it to get to that kids come and they say
yo you want to hit this you just say yo
I'm all I'm hitting that all the time in
my mind my mind is just constantly
hitting that on the the universe because
you don't you just don't need it if
you're already thinking of questions
like this it's funny you say that
because one out of four of my tweets
when I comment or reflect on an
observation I've made somebody's always
saying Neil put down the wheels
the
one that got the most was
um
in a mirror
you can kiss yourself but only on the
lips
okay
do people lost their minds on that and
it's very simple Optics but then people
said are you higher are you so I guess
it's how to get high thoughts for free
just think deep thoughts about the
physical there you go and you're there
you know they let us old enough to like
do stuff because the her earliest
queries were sent via her mother yes
remember that right that's right yeah
now she's she's like okay herself right
of age okay
so bring it on here we go uh this is
Evan Fenwick uh dear Dr Tyson and Lord
nice I'm Evan from Ontario Canada and my
question is as a science Communicator
how do you maintain your cool when
dealing with outspoken science deniers
and what advice could you offer to
people who struggle to maintain their
composure well confronted by the same
I mean how to not punch someone in the
nose yes yes you know no no you know
what it is
it's a state of mind
as an educator
it's not my duty
to educate the educated
if you confront someone who does not
know something
that's what your life is about
that session that is ready to happen
is what you live your life for
not just giving lectures just to
entertain people or it's the person who
has a twisted mental pathway knotted in
some way that needs to be unraveled uh
uh unwoven because whatever it was
weaving was losing track of objective
reality and so what you have to do is
yeah it it needs infinite patience but I
don't think of it that way
to say it needs patience implies that
without patience you would be angry and
frustrated okay you know what you know
what I don't say anger is me what
frustrates me if someone
is no longer curious about learning what
is true
and then they're angered they dig their
heels in and say let me explain to you
why the Earth is flat
that's it's harder to be an educator in
that situ in that setting you know well
you know a professor in a classroom
that's not who's sitting there in class
you know 100 people angry with the
professor because they want to keep
believing what they're they're there
ready to listen to a new thing so all I
would ask is
I if I have the patience the least you
could do is have the openings the open
just to listen to what I'm going to tell
you mm-hmm about what it is you think is
true wow and let's take it from there
that is so much more compassionate and
understanding than what my answer would
yeah
which is I'll be sure to leave you at
home next time yeah because my answer is
listen here you obtused ignorant
homunculus okay
so like a hunky homunculus is a tiny
human being imagine to be the embryo
before we had any clue how reproduction
was right exactly yeah and they were and
they were misshapen in every single way
a tiny little man a tiny little man who
was misshapen in every way and of course
because had no intelligence at all right
so uh my so another point there is I
guarantee you
that if I'm going to engage you in that
conversation
it's because as an educator I know more
about what it is you believe to be true
then you know about what I know to be
true oh wow now listen that's a great
place to be if you are trying to help
someone well my point is because if I
don't know all their reasons for why
they think Earth is flat I can't have
that conversation I'm just lecturing and
I'm just hoping they're listening but if
I know what's in the their brain wiring
I can access it and work with that and
work with them to help disinterest so
you got to meet them where they are
correct correct and to me that's an
Educators challenge not an Educator's
frustration there you go so you find
find where they are find that spot and
meet them there and then try to bring
them along to a place of Enlightenment
that is my job that is my resisting the
urge to punch them in the face
[Music]
okay like I said I'll be leaving you at
home on that pilgrimage okay where's
Lord Lord nice and Uncle Chuck nah I
didn't bring him on this education we
couldn't afford the bail money this time
that's why we didn't take stuff all
right we gotta take a quick break when
we come back our third and final segment
start talk Cosmic queries grab back
we're back Star Talk Cosmic queries grab
bag Edition I'm with Chuck Knight Chuck
what you're in some video projects
lately what do you got going on I don't
know right now I'm just I mean my Disney
show is still running uh Nat Geo panel
if you have Disney plus you can watch
brain games on the road love it I'm
still doing that and uh I am uh you know
I'll I will announce it here because we
are settling up on the Deep final
details but Star Talk fans will be the
first
to receive an invitation to come to the
taping of my comedy special
which will be only about science wow
foreign
I'm doing a comedy special just science
nothing but science whoa yeah so and I
took some of the uh some of the material
for discussion or jokes from uh Neil's
latest book so it's kind of it's kind of
cool well the book is just touches
everything in our civilization and
that's what comedians that's the fodder
for comedians right is civilization so
I'm happy to serve that role will you
give us details when it's ready yeah and
we were totally we're settling up the
final date for the taping right now so
it's gonna be great and I told them that
before we make a public announcement
that I want to invite only Star Talk
fans first so they can get first access
to that they get first access to the
tickets because we're doing we're trucks
are you inviting Star Talk only because
they're more likely to laugh at your
jokes no no because they're more likely
to understand understand oh
[Music]
okay I don't want no dumb asses there
myself is what I'm saying what do you
say there what do you think about that
that's not funny by that you should have
kept your dumb behind home
yeah there's a difference between that
wasn't funny or I didn't know enough to
understand why that was funny
the result is the same the person
doesn't laugh but you know okay one of
them this stuff was funny you're just
stupid
[Laughter]
third segment let's see how many more we
can slip in here I'll try to be my my
sound bite mode okay let's do it let's
do it this is Trevor C Mills and Trevor
says greeting Dr Tyson and Lord nice
Trevor from Augusta Georgia here and my
daughters love listening to your podcast
with me my daughter Lucy has a question
and she would like to know how does
space continue to grow what causes the
expansion of space-time and how can we
slow it down
so well first of all Lucy space drinks
its milk every single crochet you know
they don't advertise that anymore oh
that's right look at me it's giving away
my age got milk it's just got milk now
it used to be milk makes you strong it
used to yeah yeah yeah yeah
and uh you know uh one of my favorite
jokes from David Brenner uh the old
comedian from the 70s
is that right okay yeah there's the
bravest person the bravest human there
ever was okay we say well who's that he
says okay that's the person
who saw
a female bovine creature walking the
countryside
and decided to drink the liquid
secretions out of its own
that's funny bravest human there ever
was okay that is a brave human oh yes
okay so I can help industry one out of
three of those questions okay the space
is expanding
because of the energy endowed in it
from The Big Bang
okay now that expansion is also
accelerating
opposite the collective wishes of all
the gravity of all the galaxies in the
universe
we do not know what is causing that
but we measure it and we call it dark
energy
does it expand what is it expanding into
what we don't know but however much
vacuum of space there is today
there's more of it tomorrow
and more the next day
and that will continue all the way up to
the Big Rip unless something prevents
the big rip and we talk about big rip in
the start talk book Cosmic queries uh
Cosmic query is a fun book
um and if if you pick that up there's a
whole section on ways the universe can
end and one of them is in the Big Rip
where we The Accelerated expansion
happens so rapidly
that the fabric of the space-time
Continuum cannot keep up with it and it
no longer stretches it rips
and I've lost sleep thinking about what
that even means so
yeah yeah so no we don't have answers to
the two of those but the first one yes
the Big Bang had enough energy to expand
for the 14 billion years that are going
on now and then some yet there's this
other phenomenon that has kicked in
and we call it dark energy yeah look at
that look at that nice job there losing
yeah okay yeah sorry I can't I don't
have all the answers there yeah when
it's not when I say I don't have it it's
not just me my my people all right it's
not my personal ignorance you're not
gonna find it someplace else right thank
you okay
so don't worry Lucy don't be like Neil
let me down I know let me go to that
other podcast where they read it cops
what's going on with the expansion no
you don't have to worry uh you're gonna
get the same answer anywhere all right
all right all right uh this is uh Zeki
uh and zakima said hello Neil sir nice
okay we can observe the first second
Dimensions but if there was life bound
to them
would they be aware of us if not does
that mean that there's possibility of
higher dimensional life forms that can
observe us but we can't process their
existence would we be able to use the
laws of physics or gravity to
communicate if this was the case yes yes
and yes right and thank you exactly
let's move on let's go to assistant
so so here's an interesting thing all
right two-dimensional life
uh let's say they exist in just this you
know in a flat surface surface
um how would they see each other well
they would only see each other along
their perimeter agile so they're agile
so their skin if you will is just their
perimeter
that's all they are the perimeter and
guts on the inside well we hire
three-dimensional people we are
three-dimensional people we can see
inside their bodies
hmm
because there's no skin separating their
two-dimensional existence from our
three-dimensional existence their skin
is only on the other two Dimensions
right on the perimeter so we so we could
go in and do we can do surgery on them
without cutting them open
skinless flounder people so by the same
analogy we three-dimensional people if
there's a four-dimensional creature that
sees us
they see our entire innards
and I would love to write a science
fiction story where they have
four-dimensional medicine
where the surgeon jumps into a fourth
dimension right every one of your organs
just on display the way we see all the
organs of a two-dimensional uh
creature and they just reach in clear
out the arteries replace the organ fix
the organ and then they never had to cut
you open for it
and cutting you open part is a big part
of the recovery from surgery it's
healing from having been cut open now
how might we communicate I'm guessing we
could write some letters in our three
dimensions and they'd be able to see it
they can see our innards they can see
what our writing is and what is writing
if not two-dimensional information when
you think about it right right yes right
correct not right but correct right so I
don't see why we could and they would
have to then write something they'd have
to stoop to create something in three
dimensions that we could then read or
ideally in two Dimensions which is our
more familiar form of communicating in
in the written word uh if they speak
their sound waves I don't know how
they'd get into our I'd have to think
about medicinal sound wave look like I
know I'd have to think about that that's
what that would mean for us yeah yeah
I'm still stuck on like
you know like a Klein bottle like I I
can't even oh I look at the renderings
of that I mean you know that's a fourth
dimension a four-dimensional bottle yeah
and I ca I'm telling you it's that's a
whole other I can do we should do a
show I could I have spent
way too much time
sitting and trying to figure out
yeah it's a real Iron bottle a Klein
bottle has no inside no inside right
yeah yeah right so interesting yeah it's
really really cool but you know but four
dimension so I can't even I can't even
wrap my mind around a four-dimensional
sound wave yeah yeah I have to think
about that because if we use sound they
might have some other sensory way to
receive information sound might be too
primitive for them you know right
exactly yeah right okay next wow that
was so good so
okay how about this Cicero artifan says
hey Dr Neil Lord nice Cicero from
Toronto Canada I want to know when we
use a pillow it is Fluffy because it has
air between the foam or the feathers but
what would a pillow look like
in space
so now I don't know if he means like in
the actual vacuum of space vacuum of
space or or like just out in the in the
like the space station yeah no no in the
vacuum in the vacuum you have to be in a
vacuum it's not just zero g it's the
vacuum so it's not sim a pill to soft
not simply because it has air in it
there are plenty of things that have air
in it that are not soft like your tires
uh well okay sure that's a good example
but I was trying to think of something
more rigid like a dry sponge oh wow okay
you would not use a dry sponge as a
pillow because it's kind of I would
because I cry when I sleep
oh it's not oh no it's not tears the
snot that came out of your bunny ass
nose
so it's because the material is flexible
okay
so and it has a restorative texture to
it
I so two things would happen
if you took a pillow that had air in it
and took it out into space the pillow
would flatten instantly
um
but
because there'll be no air holding up
the things but then the the texture the
the restorative force of the material
will bounce it back and I think you
would still have spongy things because
the spongy because you're not being
spongy on the air you're being spongy on
this on the material on the material
correct the memory foam the material
makes all the difference in the world
it's just it's not just simply if
there's air in there it does the thing
restore its shape once it's compressed
so you it'll have to go through a
decompression moment where all the air
comes out then it goes back to shape and
then it's a regular pillow at that point
but you'll still need to breathe you
know you'll need to the right breathing
apparatus well you'll be dead because
you're well you'll be dead you're in a
vacuum of space your pillow will be fine
right rest in peace with that pillow
all right this is Frederick Johansson
and this is Frederick says hello
Frederick here from Sweden
um and it's Friedrich he gave me the
pronunciation
and for Johansson have like extra A's
and extra s's in it no no
okay he says my question to Lord nice
and the good doctor is if photons have
energy and energy equals mass
does that not mean that photons have
mass
okay so two two fast points here
photons are pure energy Pure Energy
there is a mass equivalent of that
energy right but while the photon is
energy it does not have mass all right
okay it is pure energy and so uh now you
can ask well if it doesn't have mass why
should it Bend according to gravity
right but it turns out gravity as the
curvature of space this is if the photon
follows the curvature of space it knows
no other job in this world but to do
that that's awesome but in addition the
original 1919
Clips Expedition by Sir Arthur Eddington
to test Einstein's general relativity
that light would bend near a gravity
source so you wait for a total solar
eclipse because now you can see stars
right up to the edge of the Sun and you
can see is there position the same as
when the sun isn't there and then you
can see that the light bent here's
something nobody talks about
the light would have bent even without
Einstein's theories but have only been
half as much because with Newton
with Newton you don't need Mass
to then respond to the existence of a
gravitational field
the mass actually divides out
and it's the it's what the what effect
the field has on anything their energy
objects of any size it is the same for
them all that's why all objects fall at
the same rate heavy objects light
objects no matter how light you made
that object
neglecting air resistance it'll fall the
same rate as a heavy object right to the
point where it has no mass at all such
as a photon
so yeah
that is so fascinating oh here's an
experiment you can't do but it would
work right okay so you take a take a BB
and drop it okay and it let's say it
takes a tenth of a second
to hit the ground okay right take a BB
and send it out horizontally at the same
moment you dropped this right
it'll go down when Downstream from you
but it will fall at exactly the same
rate as the one falling straight down
and they'll hit the ground at the same
time right no matter how fast you send
it out sideways it will hit the ground
at the same time as the BBU dropped
straight down it'll land miles down the
road depending on the speed you sent it
but it'll hit at the same time right on
up to a beam of light
send a beam of light a tenth of a second
later it hits the ground
wow that is crazy but it would have gone
you know 18 000 miles off to the left it
wouldn't be on Earth at that point but
the point is a gravity operates on all
objects
in the same way and even when it's not
an object if it's energy such as light
so it's a great question it really is a
tremendous question thank you Friedrich
in Sweden
it's very cool man Friedrich in sweet I
don't have to we don't have any more
time Chuck oh man do you have a fast one
is there like really really really fast
one let me see here uh there it is hey
this is uh Cameron Bellamy hey Chuck hey
Neil my wife Brook Bellamy from
Baltimore wants to piggyback on my
patreon account to ask oh
you tell Brooks he better give us five
hours okay
Chuck don't play I'm a nice guy here but
Chuck is the mean one I said uh Brooke
says this would it be possible to see
evidence of previous life on planets
that may have once had life but evolved
out of being able to sustain it so yeah
so it wouldn't continue to influence the
atmosphere as we do as life on Earth
actively
adds oxygen not we don't know how to put
the plant life adds oxygen to our
atmosphere right so that's evidence of
life on Earth where you can see from a
distance using Spectra without having to
visit the planet's surface but if there
was once a civilization
and it's no longer there and the
atmosphere had a chance to equilibrate
and be its own thing right without the
presence of life you're gonna have to go
to the planet you got more unless
spiritually you won't be able to see it
correct or you need some kind of
powerful scope that can see the remnants
of apocalyptic cities and things which
we don't have the resolution to do for
distant planets but otherwise you've got
to go there and dig around and that's
what we're doing with Mars there's no
evidence of Life on its surface uh maybe
there's life uh under the soils under
the and so with awkwardness
so that's all the time we have and books
yeah I got to go with chuck on this one
she's bogarten Brook is bogarten you're
the husband's account yeah that's right
join patreon Brooke
next time it'll be under pseudonym right
exactly right
from Baltimore next time he'll be like
hey it's Cameron Bellamy I got divorced
and my new wife Joyce went like okay
like we know it's you Brooke we know
all right we gotta go uh this has been
Cosmic queries grab bag they think it's
your funnest category Chuck a lot of
grab bag it is all right till next time
on Star talk I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist keep
looking up
foreign